Trascrizione: Irene Andreoni
Revisore: Silvia Monti
Buon pomeriggio.
Che emozione essere qua con voi.
Ho il cuore che mi batte a mille,
ma normalmente mi dicono
che ho un cuore di pietra.
Se è di pietra, io mi auguro davvero
che sia come questo.
Ho chiesto agli organizzatori:
“Ma perché devo venire a parlare a un TED?
Io faccio un lavoro strano,
che cosa avrò mai da dire?”
E loro mi hanno detto: “Parla di te”.
D’accordo, togliamoci il dente.
Parliamo di me.
Dunque, ho 53 anni,
i capelli bianchi naturali,
ho tre figli, due cani,
un marito che mi sopporta
e tutte le mattine
alle otto e mezza da sette anni
porto le mie figlie a scuola.
Cosa succede?
“Ehi, sei tu quella dell’Egizio?”
“Sì”.
“Ma che meraviglia, sarai archeologa!”
“No”.
“Ah, no, allora sei egittologa!”
“Sei restauratrice!”
“No”.
“Sei un’addetta alle sale!”
“No, sono il direttore gestionale”.
Ma che cosa fa un direttore
gestionale in un museo?
Un museo è un’impresa culturale.
Il direttore gestionale gestisce tutto
quello che è relativo al back office:
contratti, acquisti, rendicontazioni,
HR, progetti speciali, fondi europei,
back office, coordinamento
attività di servizio, mostra itinerante,
bandi di gara, formazione,
consulenze e finanza.
Ecco, nei primi dieci anni di lavoro
quello di cui mi sono occupata
è stata la gestione di 50 milioni di euro.
I 50 milioni di euro
ci sono serviti per passare
da così a così.
Siamo diventati un museo di archeologia
assolutamente contemporaneo.
Tre anni di cantiere,
1.080 giorni di lavoro,
110 operai che mi giravano
per il building,
un milione di visitatori
dal 1° aprile 2015 al 1° aprile 2016,
ma nel frattempo non abbiamo
mai, mai chiuso il museo.
Insomma, eravamo lanciati
verso il cosmo della cultura.
L’Egittologia internazionale ci guardava
con curiosità, e non solo loro.
E poi è arrivato il COVID.
Panico.
Silenzio.
Vuoto.
Che cosa possiamo fare?
Che cosa dobbiamo fare?
Cos’è un museo che sta lì,
fermo, immobile,
il portone chiuso?
Beh, abbiamo messo a riposo la collezione.
Come vedete in questa foto,
i papiri stanno lì e riposano.
Ma questo non era il museo
in cui noi eravamo abituati a lavorare.
Quindi, dopo i primi
momenti di difficoltà,
abbiamo deciso veramente,
veramente, veramente
di mettere in moto la nostra creatività.
Abbiamo deciso di parlare
un linguaggio nuovo, quello digitale,
quello che non è così propriamente consono
rispetto all’attività museale.
Abbiamo messo tutti
i nostri prodotti video online.
E poi, soprattutto,
quello che abbiamo fatto,
abbiamo messo il direttore
dentro il museo, a museo chiuso,
e abbiamo registrato ore, ore e ore
di passeggiata con il direttore,
Christian Greco, vicentino,
un genio, veramente bravissimo.
Lui che cosa ha fatto?
Lui ha veramente raccontato
la collezione, il museo,
la memoria storica,
quello che il nostro oggetto nasconde,
i nostri oggetti nascondono.
E poi abbiamo fatto
una vera e propria serie TV,
che abbiamo messo
sul nostro canale YouTube.
28 episodi per 14 settimane consecutive.
Abbiamo tenuto veramente compagnia
al nostro pubblico
in un dialogo continuo.
Però poi, a un certo punto, abbiamo capito
che l’emergenza, il momento
che sembrava temporaneo a tutti,
stava diventando strutturale.
A quel punto,
abbiamo rilevato che forse dovevamo
raccontarci in una modalità diversa,
dovevamo anche dire se avevamo
bisogno di qualche cosa.
Volevamo creare una relazione
con il nostro pubblico,
non solo raccontare la nostra collezione.
(Musica)
(Video) Narratrice: Mi interrogo spesso
su cosa spinga le persone
a venire al Museo Egizio.
La risposta che mi do
è che in questo museo
si parla della nostra umanità.
La cultura materiale ci racconta
le storie di donne e di uomini
vissuti migliaia di anni fa.
Testimonia la vita delle persone,
ma è anche un documento
per capire chi siamo noi oggi,
come possiamo trovare
il nostro posto nel presente
e come possiamo affrontare il futuro.
Quando passeggiando tra le sale
riconosco oggetti o abitudini
che sono parte della mia vita,
improvvisamente i millenni si abbattono
e riesco a identificarmi in coloro
che mi hanno preceduta,
a immaginare i loro sentimenti
e a provare le loro emozioni.
Unici ma fragili, come le storie
che custodiscono,
i reperti hanno bisogno di cure
per continuare a narrare
le vicende di un passato
che ha ancora molto da raccontare.
I musei parlano di noi,
sono la nostra biografia.
Il Museo Egizio è il luogo
in cui tantissime persone
hanno costruito un po’ della loro storia.
Molti ricordano di essere
venuti qui da piccoli
e tanti ragazzi hanno fatto
la loro prima esperienza in un museo
proprio in queste sale.
Alcuni di loro, poi, hanno deciso
di continuare a studiare
questa meravigliosa civiltà.
Per alcuni mesi,
il Museo Egizio è stato chiuso
e immediatamente abbiamo sentito il dovere
di portare il museo
nelle case di tutti comunque
e abbiamo dato voce ai reperti
continuando a stimolare la curiosità,
anche attraverso
il racconto della ricerca,
che non si è interrotta neppure un giorno.
Per far viaggiare questa incredibile
astronave del tempo che è il Museo Egizio,
ti invitiamo a salire a bordo.
Anche il tuo contributo è fondamentale.
Dal 1824 ci prendiamo cura
di questa collezione straordinaria.
Scegli anche tu di prenderti cura di ME.
Samanta Isaia: E poi abbiamo cercato
di rispondere alle necessità
del nostro pubblico tutto,
del nostro pubblico variegato.
A novembre del 2020,
ci siamo ritrovati nella sala CDA,
tutti insieme appassionatamente.
Il gruppo della didattica ci ha presentato
il primo esperimento di laboratorio
in DAD, in didattica a distanza.
Non ha funzionato.
Abbiamo preso il progetto,
l’abbiamo stracciato
e l’abbiamo buttato nel cestino.
Perché?
Perché avevamo tradotto
una passeggiata in museo,
che fisicamente si faceva lì,
a museo aperto, davanti alle vetrine,
in una passeggiata virtuale.
Non ha funzionato.
Era noioso.
Eravamo atterriti.
Abbiamo detto:
“Il caos! Che cosa facciamo?
Non siamo in grado di esprimere attraverso
un laboratorio di didattica a distanza
quello che noi siamo”.
E allora abbiamo assunto
delle professionalità esterne,
capaci di andare oltre lo schermo,
capaci di insegnarci
come fare didattica a distanza.
E poi abbiamo preso le mie due gemelle --
sono lì, nella foto --
le abbiamo messe davanti allo schermo,
abbiamo propinato loro
un sacco di tematiche
e le bambine ci hanno illustrato
che cosa potesse essere interessante
per delle bimbe di quarta elementare.
Poi abbiamo fatto la stessa cosa
con le loro classi.
Le maestre e i bambini
ci hanno preso per mano
e ci hanno portato lungo un nuovo modo
di fare didattica a distanza.
I bambini ci hanno detto: “Ma noi
vogliamo capire cosa fate voi, museo,
chi è il direttore,
perché è diventato direttore,
perché gestite una collezione
come quella egiziana”.
(Video) Christian Greco: Cari ragazzi,
benvenuti al Museo Egizio.
Ve lo voglio dire in egiziano:
ēēuy em ḥotep, benvenuti in pace.
Chissà se qualcuno di voi
alla fine di questo viaggio
avrà imparato magari un segno geroglifico
e riuscirà a scrivere
nel proprio diario “ēēuy em ḥotep”.
Pensate che bello, “Benvenuti in pace”.
E allora un po’ vi invidio,
perché oggi state per cominciare
a fare un percorso per queste sale.
State cominciando a scoprire
i personaggi, i nomi, le persone
che sono vissute migliaia di anni fa,
che hanno delle storie da raccontarvi.
Queste storie noi le scopriamo
proprio nei testi,
perché gli Egiziani
impararono molto presto a scrivere
e a mettere per iscritto le loro gesta.
Pensate, molto spesso
nelle tombe leggiamo:
“Io sono stato il semeruhati,
l’unico amico del Faraone,
e per questo il Faraone
per me ha trasportato la pietra,
per questo ha costruito
questa tomba per me”.
E grazie a queste informazioni,
noi ricostruiamo le storie,
conserviamo la memoria,
facciamo in modo che le persone --
perché voi pensate di vedere oggetti,
ma dietro a questi oggetti
ci sono delle persone,
delle persone che questi
oggetti hanno voluto,
che hanno dato degli incarichi
a degli artisti,
che hanno fatto in modo
che questi frammenti di statue,
questi corredi decorassero le tombe,
pensate, non per pensare
a qualcosa di triste,
ma perché la loro vita
potesse proseguire per sempre.
E a me, se vi posso confidare un segreto,
è proprio quello che affascina
di questa magnifica civiltà
che si è sviluppata migliaia di anni fa
nella sponda meridionale del Mediterraneo.
Il pensare quanti sforzi essi fecero,
come impiegarono i migliori artisti --
li chiamarono davvero
da tutto il mondo allora conosciuto
perché potessero venire a decorare,
a mettere su pietra, letteralmente,
le scene che li ritraevano
mentre coltivavano la terra
alle sponde del Nilo,
mentre viaggiavano nelle loro barche,
mentre incontravano delegazioni straniere,
perché noi migliaia di anni dopo
potessimo ricostruire quasi
come una storia a fumetti
quella che era stata la loro vita.
E allora voi oggi state
per iniziare a conoscerli
e vi auguro, auguro a qualcuno di voi,
che avvenga quello che è successo a me
quando avevo un po’ più della vostra età,
avevo 12 anni,
ed ebbi la fortuna di andare
per la prima volta in Egitto
e fuori dal tempio di Abu Simbel,
il tempio costruito
dal grande Faraone Ramses II,
decisi di diventare egittologo.
E questo sogno,
che all’epoca era un sogno,
mi ha accompagnato per tutta la vita,
mi ha portato a trasferirmi,
andare a studiare in Olanda,
sempre perseguendo però
il risultato che avevo in mente:
poter un giorno dedicarmi
a tempo pieno a studiare,
a dare voce a queste persone
che sono vissute migliaia di anni fa
e che voi fra poco
comincerete a conoscere.
(Musica)
SI: Sapete, i bambini quando vedono
questo videomessaggio del direttore
battono le mani.
Quindi, da marzo a maggio 2021,
noi abbiamo fatto lezione a distanza
a 12.750 studenti.
Guardate le due regioni con le bandierine,
Sardegna e Basilicata.
Nella storia del museo,
nessuna scuola era mai arrivata in visita
al Museo Egizio da queste due regioni.
Con la didattica a distanza, invece,
oggi noi siamo entrati nelle scuole.
A museo chiuso, i bambini hanno comunque
l’occasione di visitare il nostro museo.
Ma stiamo andando oltre.
A fine giugno inauguriamo
una nuova sala, la sala della vita.
Perché è giusto raccontare
quello che ci raccontano
i resti umani che gestiamo.
E ancora oltre:
nel 2024, inaugureremo un museo
molto più grande, completamente rinnovato,
assolutamente in linea
con i nuovi trend museali.
E nel frattempo, durante il COVID,
la presidente e il direttore
hanno anche scritto un piccolo saggio
di visione strategica,
quello che è il museo.
E quando l’ho letto,
mi sono presa questi appunti,
perché per me sono appunti importanti,
che qualificano
la mia giornata lavorativa.
Il museo è un luogo di appartenenza,
di restituzione, di opportunità,
di continuità, di inclusione,
di dialogo, di storia, di comprensione.
Il museo è un organismo vivente.
Il museo è un campo magnetico,
perché attrae professionalità,
idee, visitatori
e vive di quelle professionalità,
di quelle idee, di quei visitatori.
Quindi, tornando a bomba:
che lavoro faccio?
Faccio il lavoro più bello del mondo.
Lo faccio con passione,
cerco di farlo con competenza.
Il resto lo fa la vita,
quella vita che i musei raccontano.
Grazie.
(Applausi)